we have a very simple focus and idea the
goal wasn't to make a huge community
site is to make something where you
could type in someone's name and find
out a bunch of information about them so
I took a few days and just threw
together Facebook and launched it on
February 4th 2004 in the last tech
bubble most web sites were on using
these really expensive machines which
made it that you had to basically go and
raise money before you could do anything
we ran the site originally for $85 a
month are we trying to optimize news
feed to give each person all of you guys
the best experience when you're reading
or are we trying to help businesses just
reach as many people as possible and in
every decision that we make we optimize
for the first four making it so that
when for the people who we serve who use
Facebook into a reading newsfeed get the
very best experience that they can and
that means that if a business is sharing
content that's gonna be useful for them
then we'll show that but that means that
if the business is sharing content that
isn't gonna be useful for them we may
not show that because it's probably more
important that they learned about their
friend who had a baby and their baby is
healthy so that's an important guiding
principle for how we think about this
stuff then as the as the products
continue to develop there is just going
to be more people sharing more things
and we're going to continue to try to do
our best at its showing the best things
that we can so if you're a business
owner and you're thinking about how to
use your free page on Facebook I would
just focus on trying to publish really
good content that's going to be
compelling to your customers and the
people who are following you you just
watch - amazing clips of Mark Zuckerberg
take the next three minutes and sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]